so from the late 80s even up until now
um
2021 um i studied with um
i studied and studied study with some of
the elements
and the basic sciences theology
look spirituality i have some
authorizations or jazz arts in that
uh my secular background is that uh in
the
in the early 80s i started a degree in
astrophysics
i never completed it but i did follow it
up as a
you know uh in later days so i kind of
do keep up with
that kind of side of things that kind of
side of science
uh it's a passion of mine in reality uh
there doesn't have to be a dichotomy
it doesn't have to be um science or god
or science or religion
it can quite comfortably be uh
science and religion there are you know
possibly tens of thousands of of muslims
uh quite often young uh gifted
uh men and women muslim men and women
who are ending
entering into university into college
and they're confronted with these issues
um
and they turn to sources in the muslim
community to find
answers um often they feel let down and
then there are
people who aren't you know students or
whatever they're you know there are just
seasoned adults who themselves they
they're not quite sure as parents i'm
not quite sure what to tell my children
i gave a talk in uh one of the uh
islamic society
events uh in uh in london
in one of the universities in london and
this university in london is one of the
uh uh universities for medicine in
london it's one of the premier
uh universities for uh doing medicine
and uh i said oh normally we have uh
talks on wednesday the islamic societies
normally have talks on wednesday because
uh wednesday is like half day for most
universities they said yeah i know we
decided you're on thursday because
we just had a biology class i said oh so
what the
biology class now and uh the brother
said yes
i said oh but this room is fully
attended like there's like there's about
you know
60 80 people here but do they all kind
of not
attend biology or whatever he said yes
i said oh right i said why is that
he said oh it's just evolution and none
of us muslims
we don't attend any class on evolution i
said why he said oh because it's just
it's all rubbish right i said you know
had you not been studying medicine
i probably would have let that go
bismillah that's your view
khalas what can you say it's not you
know but you're studying medicine right
you can't be having that view and so i
you know we went through
some of these issues and whatever i
think about
a month later two months later they
called me for another talk and this time
i noticed it was on a wednesday
and the brother then writes to me saying
we're all attending the classes
evolution or not you know we get it now
beyond that which it can bear so allah
is giving you
you know what you can handle allah
wouldn't would not overburden you so may
allah make it easy for you continue to
make dua and trust allah
that he will make it easy allah says
indeed after hardship there is ease now
if you listen to newman ali khan's like
tafsir of this
allah says that twice indeed after the
hardship
there is ease indeed after the hardship
there's ease and with the arabic allah
says
like the hardship in both sentences
implying it's the same one hardship
and then when allah says ease he just
says ease he doesn't say these
so that's implying that for every one
hardship and it's not
like huge difficulty it's just any minor
difficulty
there's two amazing blessings of ease
that come your way some scholars say
it's just two eases generally one so
others say one in this life one of the
next
allah says these are days that we flip
between the people good and bad
and this doesn't have to be days uh it
could be you know years
uh just situations but trust allah
that he will make the situation easy for
you eventually and that you will get out
of this eventually and don't lose hope
in allah
allah says um
in this context allah says you know
those who committed sins obviously you
haven't committed a sin here but
allah says do not despair in the mercy
of allah so i want to pass that message
forward to you
do not lose hope in the mercy of allah
don't think that allah you know
will not alleviate you of the situation
definitely allah will insha allah
and uh if you don't find some kind of
refuge in this life you will find a
beautiful reward
and hereafter
ladies and gentlemen you are now tuned
in once again to the realest podcast in
the dunya
the three muslims you are joined with
your hosts
and angel we got a very special guest
today
yeah so sheikh tell us a little bit
about yourself for any new viewers that
don't know um
who you are or aren't familiar with much
of your work
um truth be told uh by the fire there's
not much to tell
um i am born and bred in london
i started kind of um to use the phrase i
started practicing islam back in the mid
80s
there wasn't much going on either here
or over across the waters in the united
states at that time
um i started working
um i started getting into dower in the
mid 80s and there was a there was an
organization
uh called gym ass uh in the uk
um i was uh one of the main workers
along with that organization for a
number of years
um by the late 80s um doing dao without
any formal studying
uh obviously showed itself
with mistakes errors
sometimes harshness sometimes being
strict when there was no reason to be
strict sometimes being too lenient
when actually there was firmness
required because there wasn't a
legitimate difference of opinion
and the only way to resolve that was to
actually start studying
formally so from the late 80s even up
until now
um 2021 um i studied with
um i studied and studied study with some
of the elements
and the basic sciences theology
look spirituality i have some
authorizations or
jazz arts in that my secular background
is that
uh in the in the early 80s i started a
degree in astrophysics
i never completed it but i did follow it
up as a
you know uh in later days so i kind of
do keep up with
that kind of side of things that kind of
side of science
uh it's a passion of mine um
i have a website called the humble eye
dot com
um and i blog translate
uh on there and from the last 30 odd
years i've
i've been teaching uh doing classes
um talks conferences
the usual the usual stuff
uh with the usual culprits
subhanallah rami are you mind blown what
an
intro yes subhan allah allah
astrophysics here
don't ask me too much i i i i stopped in
the um
uh by the second year and i decided that
i'm going to go into full-time islamic
islamic studies and start learning you
know
sharia indeed so that's what happened
really
subhanallah may i reward you for
and a pleasure to meet you all uh for
the first time marshall
um i'm sensing that you're three
different characters
oh yeah together
i'm sure it makes for a brilliant
podcast with you alhamdulillah
reward yourself you know and uh thank
you the pleasure is mine for inviting
you
i mean uh so
quick thing before rami uh takes over um
you know any of your links any of your
websites your socials i'm gonna link all
of them in the description box so for
anyone watching this far if you want to
follow along
get more of sheikh abba aliyah
take over man because we live in a world
today where people think it's either
evolution
or god yeah that is i actually opened a
dm i i made a post and on my post
someone commented open my dm
so i'm like okay okay chill i open the
dm there's a list of questions and one
of those
is evolut the first one is evolution
islam there's so much proof for
evolution
how can islam be true if evolution is
true and it's a lot of people still
think it's a really
big problem so can you please get into
that a little bit more and talk about
how
science in islam can be compatible even
when dealing
with with evolution in some sense
um it is a problem it's a problem
worldwide it's not just a problem
uh within muslim communities uh it's a
it's a problem
even with um atheistic communities i've
come across
atheists and agnostics who um
are very skeptical of science of course
it's not for them
science or god but they're skeptical of
science they're skeptical of evolution
okay uh but yeah it it has
uh especially in the western world uh
for the last four
four hundred years or more it has become
one of those uh cliched things science
or religion
science of god um
and that has that has a lot to do with
uh
western history christianity in the west
more than it
actually has to do with the history of
islam per se
um and and those those of you and
those of the viewers who've read about
it and uh
will understand what uh what i mean but
in reality
uh there doesn't have to be a dichotomy
it doesn't have to be isla you know
science or god or science or religion it
can
quite comfortably without twisting in
the case of islam without twisting
uh the texts of revelation the text of
the quran or the
or the sayings of the prophet salallahu
it can quite comfortably be
science and religion
okay um that is not to say that we
believe that the quran
is a book of science and nor that it
contains it nor necessarily that it
contains
explicit scientific verses that is not
to say it does or it doesn't
it's just to say that it's my main focus
is what
a book of guidance to connect us to the
creator of creation
that it talks about things to do with
the natural world
that it talks about things to do with uh
creatures in the sea uh creatures in the
air that it talks about
some some things to do with mountains
and how firm they are
that it may talk about in certain verses
to do with the growth
of the uh of an infant child within the
womb of its mother
uh they are not there primarily
as kind of scientific uh
evidences or statements they're
primarily there as
ethical um spiritual uh
devotional uh teachings
which connect us to god but what is
remarkable perhaps
and i don't know how you all feel about
this it's remarkable not so much that oh
there are statements in the quran that
agree with modern science
but flip it on its head um modern
science
has yet to show anything
where it's incompatible with what the
quran is saying
for a book that was revealed 1400 years
ago
where the dominant scientific paradigms
were
vastly different than what they were
what they are now
um for you know for that to be the case
that there is
nothing that modern science has come up
with
which clearly contradicts uh explicit
unequivocal verse or meaning of a verse
in the quran
that in itself is subhanallah that's
worth pondering
you know i think yeah hundred percent
subhan allah and we find a lot of the
time
dais they they use uh scientific
miracles in the quran to argue for islam
how do you feel about that that line of
arguing
so for example there is a verse in the
quran
uh that will that will speak about how
the heavens and the earth were once
joined and then god
split them asunder or
um how uh that allah
god is uh is expanding the heavens
so let's take the last one god is
expanding their heavens
so i have a classical book of a muslim
commentary
tafsir book at home i'm i'm i'm sure i'm
not the only student of knowledge that
has that
i'm sure many other people around the
world have it uh it's by a spanish
scholar
uh one of the andalusian scholars in the
uh fifth islamic century or sixth
islamic century he wrote it
and when he comes so that's you know
sixth islamic century we're talking
about
around about the kind of the medieval
period at the 12th century of the common
era
right okay just just just after the last
of the crusades
all right um when when the modern united
states wasn't
quite a nation yet not until the next
five six hundred years
uh and and britain had certain kings
doing what kings do and this spanish
scholar muslim scholar writes
under uh comments under the verse and we
are expanding the heavens
and he says the scholars of tafsir
the scholars of quranic explanation
say it has three one of three or four
meanings
and and these meanings go back to some
of the sahaba and the some of the
companions
and their and their students he says one
of the verses
uh one of the sayings we're expanding
the heavens means we're sending rain
down from the sky
god is sending rain down from the sky uh
another another uh opinion we are called
god causes vegetation to grow from the
earth
another opinion is i think i think it's
sending the wind
and then the fourth opinion he says uh
or it could just mean
the heavens are expanding and he says
they are not it could apply to all they
are not mutually exclusive
and other and god knows this and he
moves on to the next verse
um so it's possible that
uh that verse might be speaking about
the heavens expanding
in terms of modern cosmology big bang
expansion of the universe it could be
but generally as i said before the
primary function of that verse is not to
make us think oh
big bang expect expanding universe
primarily it's just to show uh how
kind god is and how grateful we should
be to allah
for giving us all these these blessings
and these wonderful things
if someone then goes around and say this
is the meaning
of the verse that's a brave person
because what we're actually saying is
god intends by this verse xyz
now either god intends and i have
spoken the truth about him or i've lied
on god
however that's very different than
saying it
is possible it's within the quranic
scope of that verse
without twisting the arabic or you know
reading into it
um alien things it's possible that that
verse
might be hinting at amongst other things
amongst other things the expansion of
the universe but
allah knows best so one could make
a a person of
serious islamic learning you know if she
or he
is a student or a scholar of the islamic
sciences
i suspect that they would be cautious in
how they state something because they
understand
stating something about islam he's
saying god says
and i that i'm speaking truthfully on
behalf of allah or i'm not
so um so they would probably state it as
a possibility rather than a hard
given fact and then i can kind of brush
my fingernails and say you know look how
brilliant islam is we you know we
invented modern signs before you blinked
amazing answer i think it's really
important and i'm glad that you that you
highlighted the fact that it's a
possibility
because a lot of people go with this
scientific
form of argumentation for the quran
itself and then when people
find something in the quran and then
interpret it
in a a non-scientific manner right
something that does not align with 21st
century science
or scientific understanding or a
scientific narrative they say look
islam is wrong so that's why i find it
such a big problem especially when
dealing with evolution because
why are we now using our you know the
empirical
method in the inductive methods of 21st
century
science as the uh the fundamental basis
why are we using that as the um the
grading tools essentially for it should
be the other way around as you said
so um bringing it back to the topic of
evolution which again is such a big
problem to so many people
how do you see evolution in your eyes is
it something that is a straight up lie
is it a hoax is there validity to it
you know one of the 8th century muslim
scholars
he has a nice verse in a long poem that
he wrote a long creedal
poem and in it he mentions how
what has co what corrupts knowledge and
the world
is when people uh when people
turn their backs on tough seal
on the on the nuances on the details
um so for example um and
um you know i think um you know please
forgive uh and
um you know i uh please forgive me in
terms of the viewers
if i'm going to mention something that
some of the viewers might not be
familiar with
um but in islam we have this
issue of duck lead okay
which can range from being called blind
following
to the other angle following qualified
scholarship it's a following of someone
without knowing their background proof
and in islam it's called taklid
so when the scholars are when the
classical scholars are asked
uh is this stakley this kind of
trust for authority
is it something allowed in islam or not
they will say
it's not a it's not a single case there
is a type of taqlid
which is forbidden in islam and there is
a type of taklid which is prescribed and
it's sometimes even obligated in islam
uh it you know there's nuances there
there's distinctions and and detail
um it seems to me that something as
complex as evolution
and it's a vast scope of what it says
uh is like that uh there are
distinctions there are certain parts of
evolution that a
a muslim committed to the texts of
um shouldn't feel uncomfortable with
then there are things that evolution
states
uh that the muslim should feel
uncomfortable with
and it will be an issue of can i square
the circle
but we won't know that until two things
firstly that we understand what
evolution
is saying in some detail
and secondly what islam and its theology
is saying in some level of detail
without knowledge of this or that
uh one couldn't make any definitive
claims
so if someone says oh evolution doesn't
agree with
agree with islam or the other way around
evolution is completely compatible with
islam
those generic absolutist statements um
i suspect couldn't be made from someone
who understands
evolution fairly well and islamic
theology fairly well and allah knows
yeah so uh we
i hear a lot about how dar uh darwin
himself uh was a deist for a lot of his
life he believed in god for
for a lot of his life and then there was
a little fluctuation in that
um and he himself gave a number of
things where he said if these things
fail
my theory fail like gradualism is one
and we find
i hear we're finding today graduates
gradualism is failing
um and you you find other mechanisms of
uh
evolution for evolution that are being
brought about um neogenetics nero
neo-darwinism so on and so forth what
would you say the
the common understanding of evolution uh
as wholesomely
as possible is today okay so uh
if i wind back a little and say that
um if you permit me um
i have um eight or nine points or nine
or ten points i'd like to
make and within those nine or ten points
i hope inshallah
that between ourselves uh and the
viewers the audience
uh we can collectively kind of join the
dots
and come to some kind of um
some kind of answer even if that answer
isn't definitive
but i i feel it's worth going through
things step by step
um as laborious uh as it
uh may seem one because it is
a really pertinent question there are
you know
uh possibly tens of thousands of of
muslims
uh quite often young uh gifted
uh men and women muslim men and women
who are ending
entering into university into college
and they're confronted with these issues
and they turn to sources in the muslim
community to find
answers um often they feel let down
and sometimes some of them make up their
own minds
um though it might be ill-judged of what
they think about islam
sometimes it weighs heavily on them
um and then there are people who aren't
you know students or whatever they're
you know there are just
seasoned adults who themselves they
they're not quite sure
as parents i'm not quite sure what to
tell my children
i remember back in the late 90s i gave
i gave a talk in uh one of the uh
islamic society
events uh in uh in london
in one of the universities in london and
this universe in london is one of the
uh universities for medicine in london
it's one of the premier
uh universities for uh doing medicine
and uh i said oh normally we have uh
talks on wednesday the islamic societies
normally have talks on wednesday because
uh wednesday is like half day for most
universities they said yeah i know we
decided you're on thursday because
we just had a biology class i said oh so
what the
biology class now and uh the brother
said yes
i said oh but this room is fully
attended like there's like there's about
you know
60 80 people here but did they all kind
of
not attend biology or whatever he said
yes
i said oh right i said why is that
he said oh it's just evolution and none
of us muslims
we don't attend any class on evolution i
said why
he said oh because it's just it's all
rubbish right i said
you know had you not been studying
medicine
i probably would have let that go
bismillah that's your view
khalas what can you say it's not you
know but you're studying medicine right
you can't be having that view and so i
you know we went through some of
these issues and whatever i think about
a month later two months later
uh they called me for another talk and
this time i noticed it was on a
wednesday
and the brother then writes to me saying
we're all attending the classes
evolution or not you know we get it now
alhamdulillah
um so it is a big issue um a lot of
people even before muslims
uh christians uh in in the beginning of
the 19th 20th century faced the barrage
many people lost their
their christian faith and christian
belief there are muslims who have
apostasized
and felt that they've lost their faith
because of this so it is an important
thing
so let let me lay my cards on the table
from from the outset
i i can only look at this from uh what
we consider to be
a normative orthodox point that is from
a point of view of
examining evolution in light of the
quran the sunnah
and the consensus of are of the scholars
uh that's really our weighing tall
it's how we weigh things to know what is
good bad
right or wrong ethical unethical um
so how could we then deal with the
evolution well there's two ways
one way would be to to take the main
arguments
and the main evidences of the
evolutionary
narrative as as taught in the
universities schools and colleges and in
in the well-known books uh and then
compare that with
uh the the opposite narrative the
critique of the criticism of evolution
along with its proofs and then kind of
weigh it up what is right what is wrong
what is false what is true what is you
know wheat from the chaff
and then whatever is left we can then
examine that in the light of the quran
and the sunnah and the consensus
the ijma but to do that one would have
to be a genius
to know the various fields of evolution
paleontology you know about fossils and
bones
uh evolutionary biology evolutionary
psychology
genetics and dna and make an
honest evaluation of the pros and cons
the rights and wrongs and whatever
and that could take weeks months years
or
for some professors and practitioners in
the field
decades i'm not equipped
i have no uh i have no no sound
grounding in biology let alone
evolutionary biology
uh other than doing a basic uh what we
call
ordinary level uh in in
college my my field was astrophysics
um so that's one way and that would be a
very good way except that
it would require a lot of
um specialization
and people just don't can't do that nor
have the time for that
the other way would be to say look let's
just take the standard
story of evolution as we're being taught
it
in the universities as it comes out in
books as richard dawkins and
and new atheism and whomsoever teach it
and say okay look we know that there is
some critique criticism of it the
criticism ranges from
um outright rejection you know on the on
the verge of christian creationism
to well you know it has some errors and
some shortcomings
this that the other let's leave that and
let's just say
oh let's take the let's take the
standard
narrative of evolution at face value
not because we think it's all true or
all force but that's how it's being
taught
at the moment and let's critique that or
let's
weigh that in the scales
of islam that doing that
will be will have far greater benefit it
seems to me
why one because we're dealing with what
is being taught
and we're not getting into is it right
it is wrong
it's a bit like again a side point
um in a in about a week or week and a
half we'll be in the middle
night of the month the islamic month of
shut down
this the month just before the islamic
month of ramadan
and there is this fifteenth night of sha
aban in arab
arabic laila nifsman shattered the
middle night of sha'an
and there are some hadith some sayings
of uh attributed to the prophet
in the sunnah of the in the in the sun
and march and other places
uh there are about 10 20 hadiths which
speak about the virtue of this night
that god is more forgiving on this night
than he is any other night
the thing about these hadiths is that
there is a
huge uh difference of opinion amongst
this
the hadith specialists the scholars of
hadith
as to are those hadiths authentic or not
one group of classical hadith scholars
came out and said
none of those hadiths are authentic
they're
all either weak very weak or fabricated
you know
they're a mixed bunch but nothing is
authentic and so for them
there is no authentic statement about
the virtue of that night
that night is an ordinary night and so
they treated it as an ordinary night
but the majority of hadith masters uh
and had these specialists
uh including imam ibn samia and ibn raj
abraham
they said no there are three or four or
five of those hadiths which are
which are sound or authentic and so the
knight does have a distinction
now if you and i i don't know your
background around me but if you're
anything like me
if you show me chains of hadiths even
though i've studied hadiths
uh i've studied the sciences of hadith
as part of you know and i have ijazat i
have authorization in one or two small
books and hadith
from scholars but you show me these
changes chains of hadith right
you might as well be speaking to me in
mandarin in chinese
it makes no difference at all uh
abdullah son of
abdulrahman son of this he is weak
okay if you say so bro you know i i mean
i know i could go back to the books of
the books of the narrators of hadith and
tirelessly maybe work my way through a
chain or whatever
that ban goes a whole week doing that
uh but you know uh doing that for 30 40
hadith and then
trying to weigh up and whatever that's
beyond that's beyond my pay grade
that's beyond most people's pay grade
including most scholars play great
they may be a an excellent jurist but
it's unlikely they're going to be an
excellent hadith master
of the buhari muslim caliber for example
so what do we do um uh we don't make uh
definitive statements we end up trusting
i trust this
this year i trust that scholar or i read
in this photo book
or i read that in the book and we
shouldn't make a big issue about it
we differ in our action i honor the
night i don't honor the night but we
don't differ in our hearts
uh that would be an honest way likewise
an honest appraisal of evolution
there is it seems to me even within the
scientific community
it's a bit like politics um there are
there is
there is too much to lose on this side
of that side and
trying to find an honest appraisal is
difficult so doing it this way look
let's just take the standard narrative
then we engage with what uh people are
engaging with
we're engaging with what dawkins and new
atheism are
is speaking about and from that angle we
can just say oh
okay you know what when i hear this
evolution stuff
i now know theologically in islam i can
accept
this and i can't accept that
and we can be more functioning
and functionable as a community also it
seems to me in all our notes
so that's how i i'd like to do i'm going
to do it the second way
and say look i know there's some
critique
okay uh but let's assume at face value
the standard
story of evolution is what it is
let's examine that in the light of
is islamic theology or islam's teachings
in order to do that it's worth reminding
ourselves at least in the broad outlines
what is evolution saying
okay uh it's not quite uh
um you know it's not quite evolution
says we all came from monkeys i mean you
know that's
that's you know that's one way of
looking at it but it for muslims
leave it alone anybody else's standard
leaving alone how we
how people treat us or don't treat us we
have to be
just towards people and towards
issues you know obviously i don't mean
this literally but i may not like you
rami
okay all right because like you're an
american right and
you know we brits were once powerful
and you took the ball away from us i've
got this perennial chip on my shoulder
right
but i still islamically have an
obligation
to be just to you this person here might
be a criminal
right might be a murderer might be or
you know some real devious criminal but
i still can't be unjust to him
likewise in issues um i may not like the
people
who came up with evolution i may
find that a lot of people who bang on
about evolution are atheists and many of
these atheists especially if you're in
europe and britain
they're very anti-religious fine that's
that's my uh that's my opinion of them
but what they're saying
i can't be unjust to i have to see what
are they saying and i have to see it
fairly
so in islam we have this thing uh
where the scholars say
comes after conceptualizing it properly
comes under after understanding it
properly
how can i how can i make an islamic
valid judgment
on the uh the the american constitution
if i don't know the articles of con of
the constitution
and i just think it's all about invading
countries
and you think and and you say to me
ramen you know i don't know what you've
read but
that's not really what the constitution
is about and you know based
upon my my emotive feelings and my
ignorance or my misunderstanding oh my i
just can't be bothered to find out
uh based upon oh it's about invasion i
based up
an islamic ruling on that then you'll
say abu ali look you know
that's an unjust thing likewise we need
not we mustn't be unjust in the
evolution so the first thing to do is
very briefly this is not like a
this is not going to be a degree course
or a you know
college courses it just literally
outlines
baby outlines just to remind ourselves
or
acquaint viewers who may not know much
about evolution
of what evolution is saying to get to
the point
where we can then see what islam
actually says about it so
overview of the standard account of
evolution um
quick five minutes secondly isn't
evolution just a theory
quick five minutes thirdly where are all
the missing fossils i mean if evolution
is true where are all these fossils
especially about human or humanoid
fossils fourthly
um there are some criticisms of
evolution
i'll quickly just mention them without
explaining them anyone who wants to
follow it up can do so in their own time
fifthly
let's take the standard story of human
evolution
okay that that kind of no ape to human
kind of narrative
sixthly what does islam say about the
overall fear of evolution and severally
what does islam say about
the story of human evolution so we're
gonna break it into
non-human evolution what does islam say
human evolution
what does islam have to say eightly
there is this thing that
jews christians and some muslims but
certain many jewish christians
scientists
uh jewish and christian scientists since
the 1950s and 60s
believe in something called theistic
evolution
where you can actually put god in the
equation
and make it match up with modern day
evolutionary theory
is theistic evolution islamic or not
that's the eighth one and the ninth one
whatever the answer is of these you know
uh human evolution non-human evolution
theistic evolution
we're still left with some hominid
fossil records
fossils of human-like creatures that
walked on two legs bipeds
what are they fabricated not fabricated
a joke not a joke and the tenth point is
just one small
saying to consider in all of this
inshallah so would that be okay if we
work through these things
uh and you can uh you guys can stop me
at any point in charlottesville
yeah would that work do you think of
course a hundred percent i think this is
the probably the best route to take
masha'allah like we can tell you put a
lot of uh work into this mashallah i
know it's gonna be good i am definitely
excited for it
i think it's really good especially that
you broke apart
um like human evolution and animalistic
evolution
and because a lot of the time you know
evolution's such a broad term it can
it does you know include both um but
sometimes when people say it
they mean animalistic and other times
when they say they mean
human so i think that's amazing
okay so um
so i'll be brief about all these first
thing theory of evolution the kind of
standard story
so don't worry about if i've kind of
like over generalized a lot because my
idea
my my goal here is not to actually teach
anybody
evolution here okay uh but just to give
some outline sketches so these are broad
strokes um
generally when people talk about
evolution when science talks about
evolution it
ref it's referring to way the way that
living things
change or evolve over long periods of
time
normally evolution is to do with the way
things
change or evolve over time those things
may be plants
those things may be fish right those
things may be humans
okay but it's about uh living things
evolve primarily it's about living
things evolving so it's less about
plants
living things evolving over long periods
of time by long periods i'm not about
human lifetime
i'm not talking about even the lifetime
of an empire you know 400 500 years or
whatever
we're talking about tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years those
kind of time scales those kind of
almost cosmic time scales the second
thing
uh evolution talk when it talks about
changes
how living things change we're talking
about change
primarily at the genetic level at the
levels of genes
and dna through
according to how we're taught it genes
adapting or mutating okay
and these changes in in genes
okay uh they're passed on or inherited
from one generation of species
to the next uh and that's where they say
the survival of the fittest come
comes uh comes along so for example here
is um
here is a grasshopper right okay um
a hundred thousand years ago
grasshoppers so i'm making this up by
the way
hundred thousand years ago grasshoppers
they had half the size of legs that they
do now okay they just had
little short little stumpy legs uh and
um then they get kept getting eaten by
predators that eat grasshoppers um
slowly and steadily
um for some reason and they won't
explain
what the reason is it would just be
nature selected it to happen so
we have we'll use those terms for the
time being nature selected it
that grasshoppers genes mutated adapted
and their legs got a bit longer and
longer why
to adapt to the predatory culture that
they had to get away from and because
they survived longer these grasshoppers
and they mated more
eventually over a long period of time
grasshoppers then
in general took on the characteristics
of long legs
the fittest survived okay so that's
really how the story goes in terms of
all living creatures sometimes these
changes they say
leads to micro evolution
that is changes and within the same
species
so here is a butterfly with brilliant
white wings
because it's in some place where
white and light colors are not dominant
but then something changes in the
environment
and uh the environment becomes a bit
dark you know the grass becomes greener
and
the rocks become darker or whatever and
now they can be seen
by any predator because they're standing
out
and they get eaten or killed or whatever
and so
natural selection and genetic mutation
kicks in
and they somehow adapt to
their environment and they become dark
in color we see this actually happening
okay that's called micro small scale
evolution and it we normally refer to it
as adapting
and we do that with cats and dogs right
as well we might breed
certain cats to get certain traits out
of a cat
or certain dogs to you know and that's
kind of
that that kind of inbreeding or breeding
crossbreeding is a form of adaption
then there is the one that kind of puts
religious people's heads in a spin
other times they say the changes are
macro
evolution there changes on a
significant scale whereby new
species occur
one creature over millions of years
gradually changes into an
entirely different creature so here's
this fish
over millions of years it becomes a a
land reptile
and the next few million years it turns
into a horse
right they call that micro a macro
evolution and
in the language of uh in the language of
evolution they call that
speciation changing from one
clear species to another entirely
different species
through and there is some discussion
here about
gradualism and whatever but let's let's
take that standard thing
through grant through gradual change
how gradual they're not clear okay
but gradual change so it doesn't it's
not like
one minute it was a fish and then the
next minute it was a horse
it's unlikely to be that it's likely to
be uh transitions
that's really the story and they say the
mechanism which drives this change not
god
not something supernatural it's natural
selection
the environment and random
genetic mutation if you
were to ask them what is natural uh
selection
don't ask that question it's a taboo
question because it doesn't have an
answer
uh what does it mean random genetic
mutation
because you're suggesting that this
natural selection and random genetic
mutation
that they seem to have an idea of what
they
need to be doing with creatures to help
them live
no it's all very you know it's all
very unconscious processes natural
selection
and it's something um you know it's one
of the big criticisms against
evolution natural selection why don't
the religious the religious person will
say why not say god
random genetic mutations might not say
god but
nonetheless god is out of the equation
according to them
natural selection random genetic
mutation and
as i'm sure you're aware rami
we can do good science astrophysics
biology chemistry you name it
without necessarily having to bring a
light into the equation
in the sense that i know that that could
sound disrespectful as a muslim
of course for us uh a lie is at the
center at the heart of everything
you know we don't even blink an atom a
subatomic particle
doesn't even decay or come into
existence except with the will and the
creative act of god
there is no might no might nor power
except with god and that's when we take
that
at its face value absolutely um
god is in control of all these i mean
billions is short you know billions and
billions and billions of atoms in the
whole of the cosmos
and all the subatomic particles and even
the subatomic particles within those
subatomic part
god is creating and destroying creating
destroying organizing
all of that and if we say oh that's
that's a bit difficult well
that's why we say allah you know because
god is great
there you have it but uh we can do
science like so for example
an atheist can do just as good chemistry
or biology or physics
as a theist can okay because as long as
you follow the rules
that's good science so yes in one way we
don't have to bring allah in the
equation
but it does beg the question what
exactly is natural selection what is
genetic mutation
but that's that's a story evolution then
says
three major things so if we want to know
what the pillars of evolution are
you know the five pillars of islam we
can say the three pillars of evolution
which most evolutionary biologists won't
disagree on they'll say
evolution makes claims about three
different
but related things three different but
interrelated things
firstly that all living organisms
are related by common descent whether
it's fish giraffes human beings gorillas
you know uh lions tigers whatever
buffaloes balls go back
long enough and you'll find
that their family lines merge together
the family line and then those family
lines merge together
right back to one thing
in the primordial soup that's really
what they say
and the second thing they say is that
we can now say especially with genetics
and
dna when all living
organisms split off from each other when
quote unquote human beings split off
from the great apes
when i don't know when uh i don't know
when
hyenas split off from dogs uh
we can tell you exactly when that
happened and what changes occurred at
that point
because we do that through dna and dna
sequences
and the third thing is we can tell you
the mechanism by which evolution takes
place
natural selection random genetic
mutation
as regards to the fasting organisms are
related by common descent
if we were to use an islamic term we
would say that
scientists call that cut a definitive
absolutely true as far as they're
concerned it's absolutely proven
beyond the shadow of doubt any new
discovery won't change that it will only
enhance what is already there
that's another point to bear in mind we
we do rightly say
science evolves and changes
yeah but it that doesn't mean we
we muslims have got well we human beings
have got to understand that doesn't
necessarily mean
that uh whatever science said before the
new science will completely wipe out the
old science
in some cases it might in other cases
it won't wipe it out it will just fine
tune it
okay so for example relativity
einstein's theory of relativity didn't
wipe out
wipe out newton's ideas uh
it refined it it you know gave it high
definition
and then it applied it to places that
newton's mechanic couldn't
couldn't be applied to okay
but apparently
if they find certain subatomic particles
if they find certain subatomic particles
that will literally wipe out the
existing
standard model they say okay
this is what they're saying so sometimes
when science discovers something new
it wipes out what came before and at
other times it doesn't wipe it out it
it enhances it this is one of the things
they say it won't wipe out
because it's so clear-cut how do i know
it's clear cut i don't
i am actually just following those who i
trust
can i then can i be in a position as a
muslim to say
it's not clear-cut no because i could be
lying i if i don't have the specific
knowledge
i shouldn't be talking about things i
don't have the knowledge on all i can
say is
according to these experts this is what
they say
but they need to be experts uh but
also when lineage split from each other
the dna sequences
especially in the last 10 years is
pretty incredible
i have a friend who works she works in
dna sequencing
um she did she did a phd in it and now
she works for
for some company so i remember going
through this with her and whatever and i
realized that you know
it's gone on leaps and bounds and and
there are some things in evolution
which are so now we can say there are
some things in evolution which are
factual
there are some things in evolution which
are likely to be true
but they still need a little bit more
testing
there are some things in evolution which
are probable
maybe it is right maybe it isn't time
will tell
evidences will tell and there are some
things in evolution which are purely
speculative
i mean it's just like the the scientist
she was sitting there one day or he was
sitting there one day
you know and just thought oh what about
this maybe this
yeah maybe this but it's just a hunch
okay we cannot therefore say
we cannot therefore give one ruling on
evolution
given the fact that some things are
likely to be factual
something speculative something's just a
hunch something's even false
no more than given a ruling upon the
whole of the united states of america
islamically are is the united states of
america
uh uh you know are the people are the
are americans
uh good people are bad
i don't know 200 200 million of you
right
all your you know whatever how how are
we going to give a single ruling on 200
million people
right um so likewise when things get
complicated it's difficult to give a
single ruling
generally our scholars teach us and i
i've heard one or two of my
my teachers over the decades say this if
you see someone
give a judgment on a complex matter just
as a singular thing know that that
person probably hasn't
studied it i mean they were talking in
context of islam but you can expand that
um so it doesn't really matter if we
don't really fully understand the theory
of evolution
but what we're saying is here is a rough
outline of the
standard model this is what one would
learn if they went to university or
picked up a
a book on evolution in a popular
bookshop
i don't know what your what your popular
bookshops are now
um but you know obviously you have them
um that would be uh that would be uh
the story changes over time in living
organisms
sometimes changing within a species
sometimes changing to a new species
through genetic mutation rand
around in genetic changes natural
selection
and it's very difficult to do biology
and it's
very difficult for modern biology to
make sense
outside of the teachings of evolution
it's really difficult to be honest okay
it has a the thing about the standard
version of evolution
on the whole it has a very powerful way
of predicting
and explaining things it has a very
strong
explanatory potential explanation
potential
okay uh less longer than i intended
let's be
briefer two isn't evolution just a
theory the point being is
it is the theory of evolution and you
and i when we talk
is a theory it means it's a hunch it's a
guess right
that's how we talk in in ordinary
language it's the same in american
english as it is the same in english
right
if you just say like you know i have a
theory who rob
you know who robbed the bank i have a
theory where my kind of where my burger
went right uh you know um then
it just means that you have a hunch you
have a guest
so isn't what's the big fuss about
evolution is just the guess
right unfortunately not simply because
something that not just muslims people
just people in general we have to wake
up to is that in the
in the language of science the word
theory
doesn't mean guess or hunch
if someone says why not it's because
whenever you do with science
historically science even before the
modern era
tended to take on words from a
you know from a language and then give
it a specific meaning
so for example the science of hadith
okay
i mean hadith in the in the way that the
quran uses the word hadith just means
talk
conversation but when you get to
hadith sciences it takes on a it takes
on a specific type of talk
talk that is ascribable to the prophet
salallahu
sunnah in the arabic language just meant
away
now it means a particular way of a
specific individual
and then even within islam even within
the islamic sciences
if i say the two sheikhs
and i say in islam if i say the two
sheikhs who do i mean
let me throw that at you you guys if i
say to you the two shaykhs
in islam who do i mean
two shays in islam yeah the two shaykhs
so in the you know if i was talking
about something in islam and i said
oh and the two sheikh said this or the
two sheikhs did that
who are the two sheikhs that i would
likely be referring to
did they live in the same time period
yeah yeah just assume they lived uh
the two of them live roughly in the same
time period
assume
okay so let me see i think that's his
point so let's so let me help you here
if i was talking about hadith okay
and i said the two sheikh said the
hadith
who am i likely to be talking about
bukhari and muslim
yeah buhari and muslim but if i said to
you
uh now talking about islamic history
early islamic history the two sheikhs
did this or that
it's unlikely to be bukhari and muslim
right who uh who would
the characters be here likely to be
think think of the obvious ones one of
the former that
uh early islamic history and two chefs
did this
so it will be
okay if i say the two if i'm talking to
you about the humbly school the
humbly phil for example and i say the
two sheikh
said this or that then it means ibn
kodama and ibn tamiya's grandfather
who is called manchester united and
two sheikhs ibrahimovic if i was talking
about
it would be imam noah and rafael so the
word the title two
shares actually means different things
or different people
in different subjects sometimes you can
get a a
a word that means something in ordinary
language and it means something
specialized in a science like in hadith
theory is the same in science the word
theory is it roughly means a fact
when we say that the the atomic theory
that
all the stuff in the universe is made up
of small bits of matter
called atoms and even if we know atoms
are made up of smaller stuff but
it is small that is not a hunch
that is a provable fact okay
that actually atoms are the building
block of matter i mean even though we
can go smaller than that sub-atomic
likewise the theory of relativity it
since 1905 and 1915 einstein's general
special and general relativity
it's gone it's undergone a hundreds and
hundreds of tests
and come out triumphant in each test
it's its claims are beyond
beyond uh speculation they are now so
much of the
relativity is factual and well proven
from the fact that
time slows down when objects are
traveling to close
to light speed okay to a time dilation
all of those things have been
established practically in
in in in practicing in uh laboratories
um so here theory means in science
it means an overarching explanation that
describes some aspect of the natural
world which is supported by
evidence and rigorous testing evolution
as a theory has a lot of evidence
for it in general so i'm not talking
about evolution of human beings or
evolution of rabbits i'm just about
evolution in general
and it has gone through rigorous testing
what do the scientific community use as
hunch they use the word hypotheses
when you hear a science scientist say um
i have a hypothesis
that means that scientist has an
educated hunch
which has yet to be tested
fully tested and yet has solid evidence
to back it up
when it does when it is fairly rigorous
rigorously tested and when it does have
evidence to back it up
it generally moves from hypotheses to
theory
theory in science generally means fact
it means
that under this umbrella of theory
there are a number of key things core
things which are factual
but they might also be under the
umbrella of this theory
some things which are a bit speculative
a bit
guesswork but there are certainly facts
under there
and that's why it's become a theory okay
it is embarrassing sometimes when we
find
less so christian and jewish western
theologians
but when you get muslim western
theologians
who when they respond to the question of
evolution that's always just a theory
it makes muslim scholarship
look bad and laughable okay
and uh and uh and islam simply doesn't
deserve
uh our our lack of trying right okay
it's not if we have no right to make
islam look bad
and make abrahamic monotheism look
trivial
in the eyes of the people who are in
desperate need of it
all right i've told heath of abraham one
of them
um so we can really park this car
right that oh it's just a theory no you
know what that's not a sensible thing to
say
because the word theory generally means
a fact
which is open to improvement and
modification but there are factual
things under it in chinatown
the issue of fossil records all i'll
just say is
on that just get there where are all the
fossil records
if you speak to any paleontologist or
read any book on
fossils and paleontology we all know
that actually
it's under very rare circumstances that
a fossil could be preserved
in mud or some rock
for millions of years normally the norm
is fossils and bones of creatures
crumble away to dust
you have to get the right situation than
the right circumstance
for fossils to actually be preserved
and discoverable in fact it
is a miracle that we have
as many fossils as we do we don't have
many fossils
but what what we do that in itself is a
miracle
if only we understood how difficult it
is
to find fossil bones of any insect
creature or
animal because it's not the norm
normally bones decay
in the ground
so where are the fossil records well
we'll come on to human fossil records
and leave other foster records i will
skip
the critique of the theory of evolution
because i think people could just look
look that up and the problem with us
muslims is not that we don't
have a critique of it we we have an
over-bait critique of it sometimes we
have an obsessive
extreme critique of it which is like
kind of you know pulling all the
conspiracy
theories bringing the illuminati you
know bringing this
bringing the knights templars you give
anything in the mix
um human evolution the standard story
standard story leaving alone modern
findings
which then you know add a little more
detail
just broadly four four things four
million years ago
there was this upright upright
creature that looked like a human being
okay look like a human being so it's
called a hominid
a hominid walking on two legs
uh small brain big
skeleton and we now call that
austere australopithecus or
australopithecines
these ape-like comedies that look more
like apes than they do human beings but
nevertheless they are walking upright or
close to walking upright
that's for about four million years ago
we have fossil records to show that
okay brain capacity with about a third
of the size of modern man
tiny ring two and a half million years
ago to one and a half million years ago
we have what they call homo habilis
handyman
this hominid and so i'm not using the
word human i'm using
the word human-like hominid
also homonym hominid
that walks upright okay we have
plenty of fossil records on top of those
fossil records we have
homo habilis has a brain half the size
of
modern humans and it has um
it has tools and
spears and whatever and so homo fabulous
is handyman
because it had tours homo erectus about
250 000 years ago a million years to 250
000 years ago
stronger than huma a stronger physique
than human beings
uh first harmony to hunt
uh apparently it was meant to be quite
savage i don't know how they know that
but quite savvy you you wouldn't want to
meet it on a
on a dark street okay um
homo erectus we have fossil records of
all of these
the issue is how do we account for these
human-like creatures modern evolution
will say
they are human
some modern evolutions which i say that
you know leaving the first one or two
but
homo erectus and what comes after is all
human
and we need to be careful about the
language
to say human human is one thing and to
say human like
is another why because as muslims
we need to start with the starting point
and i'll get into this with proofs later
that the first
bashar the first in san
was the prophet adam peace be upon him
whatever these creatures were we have to
account for their existence
we can't just pretend that the fossil
record
uh isn't there um so
but that is why they say modern
evolutionary biology says that
humans have been around for millions and
millions of years because they take
fossil records of homo erectus and homo
habilis and they say well look
upright roughly like us therefore
they're human
and i'm not quite sure
uh if that for muslims should be the
right way of going around things because
someone then is defining human outside
of our tradition outside of our sacred
language
we rather we say human or bashar
is what is whatever adam alaihissalam
was
and we're pretty sure he wasn't a homo
habilis or
australopithecine or whatever but we'll
come on to that
then about 200 thousand years ago and
this is where the story really gets
interesting
homo sapien wise man i mean that's
talking about us
okay uh 200 000 years ago but out of
this 200 000 years ago evolutionary
biologist says
it's only the last 40 000 years where
these homo sapiens have reached what
they call
behavioral modernity behavioral
modernity in that that these
homo sapiens about 40 000 years ago we
begin to find
characteristics in them of modern human
beings
complex language figurative art abstract
thought jewellery for adornment
cricket bats or bats playing
like i'm assuming with a ball
okay and finally made tours and burial
rituals
we only begin to find all of that 40 000
years ago
we find some primitive tours with homo
habilis millions of years ago
but the real stuff 40 000 years ago
even though this sapien creature has
apparently been around according to
evolution 200 000 years before but it's
only 40
000 years where behavioral modernity
has come so they say anything before 40
000 years ago
uh is very primitive
uh and some of them not hardly
distinguishable from apes
and anything from 40 000 years onwards
remarkably resembles modern man in in
all our diversity in china
so that brings us to the obvious
question so what does islam say about
evolution
do anyone does anyone want to interject
at this point before we get into
literally [ __ ] while giving this one
islam says about evolution yeah yeah i
had i don't know
two quick questions so what was roughly
the period of time that adam
alaihissalam was uh
was here from now brilliant
uh in the book and the sunnah uh there
is
nothing stated clearly about the time
period
so according to the islamic sources
there is no way of telling where adam
malaysia was was he five thousand years
ago
ten thousand years ago twenty thousand
years ago forty thousand it's hard to
tell
if we use a biblical sources
even that becomes problematic okay
because
you'll find biblical scholars differing
so there is nothing
definitive that says adam islam
i was around 5000 years ago we just
don't know
um we do know however that how many uh
profits
we had from adam
yeah i mean most scholars give it some
level of hassan
so so even if even if each prophet lived
one year
which is highly unlikely yeah even if
there's 124 000 years
or as i say supposing allah sent two
prophets
to each to two communities at the same
time whatever
you know for it for a year then you're
still talking about you know 60
60 000 years so the time scale of 40 000
years or 50 000 or even 100 000 years
is not improbable from an islamic
perspective so let me repeat that again
the time scale of 50 000 or even 100 000
years
is not improbable from an islamic
perspective
the beauty of islam is it is simply
silent about how long human beings have
been on earth
so they could if we could have been
around forty thousand fifty thousand
a hundred thousand who knows we but we
certainly are not committed
to the belief of five thousand five and
a half thousand years
like orthodox jews and you know medieval
christians or well not even medieval
christians that you'll find
some christians in the united states
still believe that
it's crazy um my second socialism
physical okay my second question is how
tall approximately was adam alaihissalam
um so i'm going to be brief about this
uh
though the the hadith in bukhari that
he's 60 cubits tall
so that's the size of um that's like the
size of like kind of uh
um about three three four houses on top
of each other
okay pretty tall okay but
there may be very some discussion i say
some
and not much because there's a lot of
silence on it
it's clear that he's 60 cubits tall in
paradise
it's then not so clear is he 60 cubits
tall on earth
and classical scholarship doesn't say
much more about that
but every time 60 cubits comes up or
we will return to the height of our
father in paradise
so once one sahih hadith in bukhari says
and the people of paradise they will be
the same height as their father adam
which was we know from the other hadith
60 cubits caught taught
um so so some modern day scholars
suggest
some that perhaps 60 cubits is
the adamic height in paradise
uh and allah knows best if it is only
he was that tall only in paradise or was
he that tall here on earth and allah
knows
who got any questions before he goes in
oh i said we continue okay so
so bismillah does islam allow us to
believe in the theory of evolution
well as uh brother rami kind of uh
uh nicely made clear if by evolution
oh let's take it from this way first
actually if by evolution we mean
one species evolving and adapting to
their environment
um whilst remaining the same species in
other words micro evolution
uh then yes we believe in that and to
deny this type of evolution is
islamically
unwarranted and it's kind of rationally
silly
because we've had this going on you know
from
thousands of years past you know even in
the time of the prophet salallahu
they were breeding horses okay to get
better horses and whatever perhaps not
like we moderns do but they were doing
something like that
if by evolution we mean macro evolution
one species evolving into an entirely
different one
over long periods of time then
yes we can believe in this type of
evolution providing
three conditions are fulfilled
we can conditionally believe
in this type of evolution one species
evolving into a completely different
species one living species
into a totally different living species
over long periods of time
three conditions first condition that we
don't include human beings in this
evolution we cast them out and we'll
talk about that a bit later secondly
if there is solid scientific proof
or speciation one species turning into
another
personally as just a part so this is not
fatwa this is personal and you can just
throw it out with the window if you
don't agree
i actually believe in the fossil record
of
uh a fish becoming an amphibian and an
amphibian becoming uh a type of pony or
a pony or a horse
it's one of the few full transition
fossil records and i actually
believe that actually that happened by
you know obviously by allah
however it's not like a belief as in
like you know either that i hold you
know
it's just you know from the evidence
i i i go for it just like the evidence i
i i don't think that um elon musk or
or some mega tycoon is not elon musk
who's the one who's
accused of trying to put chips into the
kobe vaccines
he's definitely one of your guys bill
gates
yeah bill gates bill gates poor soul
um you know i i don't believe that okay
now someone might say well i i think i
have evidence for it
don't take the vaccine uh but you know
um there you have it
um so i that's what i believe in this
kind of thing it's not like an akid of
atlas
but you know that's i've done my
research and i think that's the
conclusion i come to
um point being is if the scientific
proof is correct one should believe it
if it's not correct one can't believe it
if it's speculative
up in the air bismillah we don't have to
take a view
so firstly leave human beings secondly
if scientific prove
uh proof for speciation is sound and
thirdly
if this did happen like the fish to the
horse
if it did happen speciation
then i can only believe it happen with
another four conditions
one that allah is the creator of
everything
not allah was the creator of everything
allah is the creator of
everything and by everything we muslims
mean
everything we're not talking about big
things
only we're talking about everything
brother fires blinking at the moment
allah created that act it's involuntary
in us but allah is a creator
you you've got neural networks in your
brain and your synapses are firing away
as they are
with mine okay allah has created those
firing away and anything else that's
happening
that sub-atomic particle whether it's a
quark or whether it's string theory
the the alleged string theory happening
subatomically and the quantum processes
allah
allah is actively creating
recreating sustaining
removing destroying giving birth
to uh new things or creating new things
on ourselves
therefore this this fish to horse allah
at
every step of the way there wasn't a
blink of a second except that
the divine hand was involved point one
point two
nothing can happen except by allah's
will
natural selection and genetic mutation
even if let's say
they had their own power they couldn't
overpower god's will
three that cause and effect are created
by allah
and have no independent autonomy
the drink
does not quench the thirst but
allah somehow and it doesn't matter how
somehow uh allowed the drink
to quench my thirst and then muslim
theologians differ
on what the process is and we're not
required the salaf didn't get into the
process
and we don't we're not required but to
believe that the drink
can independently of god quench my
thirst
would be the fourth point shirkle
it would be to ascribe a quality
to drink in this case which only belongs
to god
fire doesn't burn in and of itself drink
doesn't quench
first in and of itself medicine doesn't
cure in and of itself
allah is the cure the quencher
the burner at every step of the way
however allah in his kindness
makes it the norm that when you put
fire to paper the normal result is
combustion
when you put water to mouth
the normal result is quenching of thirst
it's medicine to patient
the normal result in charlotte's cure
but that is not because of some
intrinsic ability within uh
the water or the medicine or white
there is no might nor power except with
and by god so
uh cause and effect are created by allah
why because he's the creator of
everything and so there is no cause of
or effect
independent or autonomous from him to
believe
in independent cause and effect
which is what they mean by natural
selection and genetic mutations
would be what we call in theology
um associating partners with allah in
terms of the worldly means
okay um
so provided and i believed in those four
things god is the creator nothing
happens except by his will he's the
creator
of cause and effect uh those things then
i could then believe if
if the science or the worldly evidence
was good
i could believe in that thing likewise
um
do i believe in the empire state
building yes i do
i believe that it once upon a time it
was the largest building in the world
and it's somewhere in
new york right new york right yeah new
york right
uh and provide and i believe that
whoever put it there
actually the the creator of it through
human beings um and i can believe in
there because
um in i've never been to new york okay
but
i've seen images of it on tv
and i have friends and relatives who
have gone to new york and have seen it
and i trust what they say and it's
mutawati
okay likewise anything in science could
be like that
i trust it or i've seen it or someone
reliable has shown me
or it's just mass transmitted because
our ulama
some of our say when allah says
and muslims help one another on the
truth and help one another
and patience truth doesn't just mean
religious truths and reveal truths
truths mean any truths
so as a muslim i'm not allowed to lie
and say there is no such thing as the
empire state building
there's no such city as new york it's
all fake news
when i know that not to be right and
why because muslims aren't allowed to
tell falsehood
about anything we can get it wrong
we can be misled but we can't
intentionally who lie about anything
or anyone lying is creed blind
color blind person blind everything
blind
truth is truth and the believer is
expected to hear adhere to it
if the science is good
one can believe in it but hey brother
fine you don't have to trust
my opinion of the the fish to the horse
transition fossil records you may see
the same fossil records as i
or read the same evidence me and come to
your own conclusion
well that doesn't really do it for me
and as long as you are being
just and fair-minded about it bismillah
why not and we still go away as
as as brothers in faith and have our
burger
okay um so we can believe in all of
these things
if the fossil records are good um
and are they good or not might be
dependent upon
our own under knowledge of it or our own
understanding of what's been
you know what is there
so but the question to ask can god
forget about did god can god make
a fish into a horse
and the answer is in islamic theology
we have three types of categories of
existence
in islamic classical islamic theology we
have three types of
existence we have something called
it must exist because you can't explain
the universe without this
thing that exists and has always existed
and that
necessary existing being is god is allah
okay and then there is
it's impossible to exist can there be
can there be
another allah alongside allah
muslim impossible allah is wide
okay laser committee there's something
like him he's white
okay um and then there is a middle
category
possibly can exist it can exist if allah
wants
and it won't exist if allah doesn't want
and we
the creation planet earth people
creatures flower and fauna and fish
he could have made us with seven fingers
let's say if that was
optimum for us he could have made us on
average
seven foot left you know seven foot ten
instead of five foot
six or whatever okay he could have made
the sky
uh uh you know purple because
the nature of light would have been
diffracted at different
way he could have we know he didn't
but they are possible for allah to do
they're not impossible
likewise can allah turn a a fish into
well
he turned a group of the israelites in
their sacred history
into monkeys and apes a group of the
israelites for breaking the sabbath
okay that was an automatic
transformation
transformational punishment um i will
take the responsibility of saying that
on my own
belief and not necessarily attribute the
belief to uh
to uh to the organizers of this podcast
um
[Music]
so can allah change a fish into a horse
the answer is
it's possible did he change a fish into
a horse well
that would require evidence can you see
the difference
can he do so if a muslim said no no
that would be a real problem with that
either
but if a muslim says yes he can but did
he that's a different entirely different
kettle of fish
oh question let's let me fish out a bit
again
this reminds me of the three categories
of rationality where it's rational
irrational
or super rational absolutely so
absolutely um and
many people today forget the last one
super rational
okay so it's either something is
irrational or it's rational
but actually uh it could be super
rational you know uh
most of the people in the west not
necessarily muslims most people in the
west will
generally say that uh every human being
is created with dignity
and is deserving of some rights you
tried to prove that rationally or
scientifically and
we get nowhere therefore is it
irrational well most people in the west
don't think so
so what is it then well actually it
comes into the third category that you
said
okay and in islamic epistemology
we have how do we know something you
know as knowledge
uh it is either through hiss the five
senses seeing
you know seeing touching tasting uh
hearing uh so on and so forth that's
hissy
ugly through rational investigation and
through logic and rational investigation
or
uh uh or through kind of religious means
that we are informed normally
religiously informed
all right are you are you familiar with
hamza torches
so he started coming to my classes some
years some years back
yeah so in my in my
you know journey to islam uh
you know especially like you know
science philosophy
physics and islam when all of that
started you know the dots started
connecting
i watched the debate between uh hamza
torches and
uh lawrence cross house yeah i'm not
sure if you're familiar with that but
yeah that debate really opened my eyes
and wonderful it's
subhanallah it's wonderful to see
brothers like you know yourself
chick and hamza and all these
intellectuals
in the ummah right it makes it you know
when you when you look at you know
christianity
uh judaism again they're they're you
know they can do whatever but i don't
see that same type of scholarship
let alone you know when you go into
hadith and faith and it goes really deep
and it's it's very
sometimes i find it more strict and you
know higher standards than scientific
principles
right so my question to you is when did
you start
um your journey into the more you know
blending the more secular you know
sciences with islam and cut
and you know taking away the dichotomy
um one of the problems i feel i've
always had
from a young child is i've always wanted
to connect dots
in anything so when i was like
you know like when i was um nine or ten
our teacher at primary school
like kindergarten school read to us the
hobbit
right uh and then that stayed in my mind
and then when i was 14
i came across the book lord of the rings
in the library
and i read that and then i just wanted
to connect the dots well where did that
come from
where where did the ring ultimately come
from it it tells you a bit
a bit about the origin of the rings in
the appendices of lord of the rings
but i went out and got the silmarillion
from the library
uh you know which was the kind of the
origin book and
you know i'm like that even on kind of
um just anything i need to know the dot
need to have the dots connected
so at some point um i i ask myself the
question you know uh
astrophysics allah is the creator of
creation i wonder did he create
how did he create the big bang and you
know can we ever discover it and
those kind of things just played in my
head and at some point i realized that
this is not just a
very fancy for what you know personal
thoughts
but people are struggling with these
issues in terms of their faith
whatever i thought oh let me take it a
bit seriously
and um and try to engage some of these
people in inshallah
uh uh hamza though marshall he's on
another level when it comes to this he's
you know
alhamdulillah he's just gets out there
um that krause debate was um
i think one of his earlier debates i
think if it ever happened again
now he's so much more seasoned
um he is much more measures in his uh
tone but even then it was a good eye
opener
[Music]
yeah definitely i mean
i mean it reinforces the philosophy that
you mentioned in brief before that as
muslims we need to be just everyone
non-muslims included and you know when
you look at the
the manners and the way he conducted
himself the character the hamza uh
uh carried himself in that debate and i
think me and ah talked about it once
um i'm sure a lot of people that came
supporting kraus
and their pro-atheists anti-islam
islamophobia whatever you want to call
it
they couldn't help but notice his his
attitude his character
but a lot of people that came maybe you
know supporting hamza
they didn't even know too much about
atheism they're probably still going to
walk away with that sour you know taste
in their mouth
by you know some of the things that i've
i've witnessed from kraus
goes without yeah alhamdulillah and
actually the good thing about it isn't
just like that
uh you know when the camera is rolling
that
generally i have found that to be his
character
uh when you just interact with him
normally as um
that's what i found of the brother
alhamdulillah that's good because
otherwise generally
we can all put on a character for the
camera unfortunately
we moderns are good at doing that uh but
actually to just have genuine character
you know people so alhamdulillah
so let me just round this up with human
evolution
the reason why we can't believe that
humans
transitioned from something earlier apes
and these apes transitioned from
something earlier still
all the way back to the primary duels
primordial soup and
you know earlier earth's early waters
is because the quran is clear the quran
is decisively clear
of how adam alaihissalam peace be upon
him was created
allah doesn't say that we did not create
uh
we we we do not make fish into
horses or we do make fish into horses
as i sign it about uh non-human living
things evolving
just like allah is silent revelation is
silent about dinosaurs
the quran doesn't mention dinosaurs the
sunnah doesn't mention dinosaurs
okay so does that mean we can't believe
in it no
it just means it's not a religious
question
it's a question of empirical evidence is
there an evidence
is there enough evidence for dinosaurs
whatever evidence that may be
if there is we can believe in it they
believe in them if they're not
we can't that's simple as that um
likewise is there does the quran speak
about
non-human evolution fish into horses
okay no it doesn't but nor does it
uh it doesn't affirm it nor deny it so
can we believe in it yes but not really
as a religious question to say
based upon evidence but when it comes to
adam al-islam human beings
bashar or insane
uh
and when your lord told the angels i am
creating a human being from
clay okay um and
uh for example elsewhere in the quran
that's
what prevented you from prostrating to
that which i created with my hands
and when your lord said to the angels i
am creating man from clay from
formed mud for it
and when i have shaped him and breathed
into him of my rule of my spirit
then full prostrate before him uh these
are a few verses of and
a fair good number of verses in the
quran which talk about a specific
way that adam alaihissalam the prophet
adam peace be upon him
uh was created that he's created
by god in a special way and and allah
has
mentioned detail of the type of stuff
adam was created from
and that eventually there is some
mystical quality that all human beings
have this rule
that allah infuses in in every human
being and infused in admiral islam
um and um elsewhere that
he taught adam the names of all things
okay uh
so it's really hard to imagine that this
is a creature
that and and the fact that the example
of
don't worship jesus just because he
didn't have a father
because here is adam who had no father
and mother so
if anyone deserves to be worshipped as a
deity or a
a as a trinitarian belief adam is more
deserving
of jesus and yet you don't do that to
adam so oh christians don't do that to
jesus as well
um it's hard then to take all those
verses and think
oh actually what god actually means is
adam had proto-human parents you know
kind of
ape-like human-like parents you know one
step away from being human and then adam
came
and was the human that's how some
christians
would see it others will just say well
this goes against revelation
this goes against religion it doesn't
there's a difference between
assuming we have no proof no
empirical proof that wherever
musa whatever sees muslim islam split
allah split for most election we have no
proofs for that
is different than saying there is no
proof
or that it didn't happen okay
that not being able to furnish your
proof is different than saying
it didn't happen because absence of
proof is not proof of absence
absence of proof is not necessarily
proof of absence
okay um so does islam allow us to
believe in the
theory of evolution um non-human
evolution we can do
if the evidence is sound if empirically
it's all there
and that will be up to every individual
muslim
uh to investigate if they want to or
they don't have to investigate and
not have any opinion about it whatsoever
although that would not be a wise
attitude to take in this day and age
given that evolution actually pulls
people away
into the realms i see realms of apostasy
uh so insane is you know uh
it's there theistic evolution
in nine i think about the 60s uh the
catholic pope
i think pope john paul ii whatever
pope said we now believe
in evolution but we believe
because the uh the evidence was
overwhelming
all the hundreds years before the
catholic church was as strong as
muslims were against this evolution idea
especially human evolution
but by 1960s they felt it's just
you have to deal with the evidences and
genetics was coming into its stride
so the catholic church took a huge turn
and said we now believe in evolution but
we call it theistic evolution
and by theistic evolution they said look
god was at the start of this
he wound up the evolutionary clock
right and then he just left the clock
there
and it unwound itself and evolution
played out as
it did very much like god kicked off the
big bang
he wound up the cosmic clock and he left
it there and it just
unfolded itself and over the next 15 000
million years
we come to how the universe is today or
as you americans call it 15 billion
years
right then they said evolution
the problem with that is
theistic evolution as the catholics and
many jews and christians and some
muslim scientists have ascribed to it
they believe that god had no hand
whereas the muslim
orthodox belief is there is not a
millisecond a microsecond a nanosecond
except that allah is creating
recreating destroying
actively you know and nothing can happen
without the creative will of a world
nothing and that means in its absolute
sense
so theistic evolution would be covered
would be a form of disbelief because it
would be
to deny that it's oh allah started it
but actually something happened
without allah the evil evolution
processes
unwound without allah
they have independent power we don't
believe that
it's actually um considered to be
disbelief in itself
and the other thing is it will be
problematic because then you're saying
that adam came through the evolutionary
process
so he did have parents they may have
been proto-human parents but they were
parents nonetheless but the quran is
clear about non-parents
and then one would imagine that baby
adam
all right comes from these proto-human
parents not quite
human but adam is the first human being
the
evolution was he speaking articulately
if the answer is no babies don't speak
articulately well
well the quran is very clear
and we taught adam the names of all
things and then we said
we said to the angels tell us the names
they said they couldn't do it
we said uh we said to adam oh adam tell
them the names and he told the angels
the names of the objects
so adam alaihissalam was born
it seems like a fully mature man
but more importantly articulate and
intelligent
is that what theistic evolution says no
um so we would have a problem with uh
theistic evolution and we would also say
to uh atheists that um
evolution doesn't disprove
adam's existence you may ask the quran
uh
why because we can quite happily say
that for some reason
allah put adam in the mix of these
hominins we could
we could say that and if we said that
it wouldn't be going against any verse
of the quran or any hadith of the
prophet
we couldn't say that as a creed we can
speculate it that yeah well we have to
account for adam
islam's existence obviously we believe
in that
so um maybe before him there are all
these hominids
and maybe this is speculation maybe you
know this 40 000 years of
modern humans homo sapiens having modern
behavioral traits
maybe that's when adam al-islam round
about that period and by the time his
his family and children and children's
children grow
that becomes behavioral modernity
he teaches these sapient beings
what it means to be human it could be
and that wouldn't
go against evolutionary teachings except
that it doesn't have any evolutionary
proof
nor would it go against any islamic
teachings as a suggestion as a
possibility
what we couldn't do is say the whole
thing is a metaphor
the whole story is is figurative because
the arabic language
is so clear people generally know when
experts of the language know when
something is figurative or not
when you make when you do metaphors or
when you make something figurative you
tell a story
for a figurative truth you don't go to
all this detail
adam lay some story in the quran is told
about six or seven different verses uh
different sort and each time it's told
in a slightly different angle
different camera shot if it's figurative
why have
seven different camera shots with
different details
if the whole thing is figurative that
actually well actually he was brought to
the
engineering why go to why does the quran
go out of its way um to then tell you
the different types of clay
that adam was made from uh
he's
from a product of mud just the sight of
you
why go through all this detail and
different textures
if it's all figurative no the language
is very suggestive of it is
a real event
it is a real event in sacred history
and we can thank allah that nothing in
evolutionary biology
disproves
the uh the existence of other malaysia
of course nothing in evolutionary
biology proves the existence
and if they uh if we were asked as
muslims but why did allah do that say
why did allah do what i suggest that he
could have done which is
maybe amongst the uh you know the
hominids were there
osteopathic is homo habilis homo erexus
okay
but actually they they weren't humans
they were human-like
but the human is maybe the one who has
the rule
and can know spiritual truths and not
just material truths
okay and maybe this 40
because they can't explain evolutionary
biology
currently can't explain what happened
at the year 40 000 years ago where did
this quantum leap come from
that all of a sudden you have
articulation you have proper structured
language not grunts and groans and you
have
abstract thought which only human beings
can do
and then you have you know delicate
jewellery and delicate tool making
paintings where did all that creativity
come from
um of course evolutionary
biologists will say oh in charlotte well
this won't say in china but they'll say
you know give us
5 10 20 30 years we might find the
answers but i'm saying
perhaps perhaps
that was the divine intervention of god
for some wise reason
and there therefore that accounts for
not only the previous fossil records
they weren't humans they were humanoids
or
hominids and it might even explain
behavioral modernity there is a clue to
this brother fire a clue a possible clue
in the verse of the in this verse of
quran and i'll begin to
to the angels he tells the angels i'm
going to create a khalifa vice gerard on
earth
and what their response is like you know
i don't want to make it into like a you
know
a drama on netflix but their response is
like a bit of a shock
will you create on earth one who will uh
uh cause corruption and shed blood
whilst we do praise
uh your holy name and glorify you and
allah says
i know what you do not know
how do the angels know that this clay
creature called adam
in whom at that time the texts more or
less tell us
the rule hadn't been infused in him yet
so they hadn't made such that to him yet
uh at that time
but they can see this clay creature and
allah says this clay creature i'm gonna
put on earth
as as my khalifa and there
they are they are a bit shocked
how do they know that this clay creature
is going to do that
is going to cause mischief not this clay
creature but his descendants
well an answer could be
an answer could be
that there were already creatures like
him before him
who weren't quite him but could resemble
him in many things
and they were just doing
madness down there when we look into our
tough syrian literature
there is nothing like this what there is
though is this
not from the verse of the quran nor from
any sound hadith not even from a
hadith but from the israelite traditions
that means traditions that we learned
from the uh
mainly from jewish rabbis who became
muslims
and then it gets some of their stories
get woven into out of syria literature
and we call them israelia
i mean israelite narrations
israelite narrations to be found in ibn
kefir and tabari and elsewhere
tell us that before adolescent was put
on earth
there were jinns on earth and they were
causing bloodshed and mischief and
whatever
and allah sent the angels to clear them
away
for adam alissa
now providing there isn't an ijma a
consensus
on this point that they were jinns and
providing it
is just a jewish
law you know from jewish law
that we took in
we didn't believe in it nor disbelieve
in it because the prophet said when the
children are
when the people of the book narrates you
neither believe it nor disbelieve it
but it's come as a story that actually
who populated the earth before adam
islam and his progeny jinns
maybe they weren't jinns maybe they were
hominids
if there is no ijmar on this point then
that gives us flexibility to
posit the possibility that maybe they
were hominids
and allah cleared them out because
of of adam islam and and what we now
call modern homo sapiens
which is insane and that could be
a possible way of squaring the circle
so in brief we can believe in evolution
of non-human species providing we
believe that the empirical scientific
evidence is
solid we cannot as a muslim
believe that adam came through the by
other evolutionary process
nor could we ever believe that it's a
metaphor because the quranic language
is just too precise clear too detailed
on top of which that there are numerous
hadiths
that adam was created from the top soil
of the earth of different colors
which is why we have the mix that we do
and the temperaments that we do
and it's very difficult to make that all
figurative or a metaphor
um and that's that's what what i
understand i've run this by some of my
teachers some of my teachers couldn't
give an answer because they just don't
understand
biology evolutionary biology and some of
them
have said that this is you know it's all
solid
as long as you make sure that you're not
making a fatwa out of yeah
um uh they weren't jin they were
hominids
and you make sure that you make it clear
that that's an opinion
that you're suggesting in the absence of
an idioma a consensus of muslim scholars
because if there is a consensus that
they were gin
then we can't break a consensus
okay so i have a very quick question um
it's not a consensus that they were they
were jin
so if it's not a consensus yeah
yeah so is it a consensus or not so as
far as i know it's not but um it does
require
i do need to look into a little bit more
but uh generally where
generally you'll find israelite
narrations aren't
a point of consensus because they just
you know we you know they're not like
prophetic statements there
the the jewish rabbis got it from their
jewish rabbi you know
we don't know right or wrong left or
right or whatever we know sometimes they
went overboarding things anyway
while we have arrangement so assume
assume for now that it's not a consensus
okay okay that's fair um so i i'm
assuming that you you haven't heard any
other opinions
indeed none of my none of my teachers
have pulled me up on that
and normally you you know that i have
one or two teachers who would
definitely pull me up on something okay
okay
uh subhanallah i think that was amazing
like especially the end attempting to
square the circles upon allah
i'm given again that it is just a
possibility it's not something that we
should go out and promote as okay this
is the
bless you bless you rami that's exactly
it you
hit the nail on the head it's a
possibility it's not something we make
dower to
yeah um
but at the same time it's really
beneficial i'd say
uh to people who are looking at
evolution
and they think okay this is the truth
there's so much evidence for it
and saying that okay it does not line up
with islam it's
this is amazing because we can go to
them and say that's not necessarily true
that's not necessarily true absolutely
and and
i personally believe that should be our
starting point
yes um on top of which the added benefit
is it gives hope
and remember your question right at the
beginning you know like kind of
um some people using science to kind of
like justify islam and whatever
it's not i i don't blame people who do
that
in the sense that if you believe on the
whole the scientific method and the
scientific enterprise is generally
true it's the best way to know the
material world we don't have a better
way of knowing the material well than
that
and if you believe that's true and you
believe islam is true then the natural
thing is to try to square the circle
just like the muslim philosophers of the
past the ibnesinas
and the ibn russians of the world greek
uh philosophical thought
was true quran was true and it was a
matter of trying to
harmonize between them which didn't
quite work out as
you know expecting and likewise a
scientific enterprise hasn't quite
worked out
uh like some muslims hoped for but it's
understandable why someone will do that
but we should just approach we should
start from the point
of i know this sounds a bit blase and i
don't mean it to sound blase but
it's irrelevant what what
non-muslims uh and anyone else thinks
outside of our tradition allah has
revealed
to us a book and he sent to us a prophet
[Music]
uh a prophet until the end of days and a
book until the end of days
and regardless of what anyone feels
about it it is not a book of science or
geography or mathematics
or it's a it's a book of guidance and he
also was a prophet of guidance uh and
you know um
that's we're not going to budge from
that point in chinatown and try to be
over over scientific or over rational
about it
yes yo rami real quick i don't want you
to give
give it away sheik how old do you think
rami is
if you want if you want if you want to
hit i'm 23 and on how's 26.
so just do some yeah so just take a
guess at home i
i imagine romney to be younger than you
both
yeah he's he's 17 no
pitched you at all the same age a
roughly the same age give or take
he's he's younger he's younger but he's
brilliant masha'allah
bless you all martial it's um
alhamdulillah it's been a pleasure i i i
hope i i hope it wasn't too tedious
but it is one of those topics that is
really hard to condense down even though
i did try my best to condense it
yeah yeah i honestly i think i think it
was amazing subhanallah i myself uh
not as brilliant as fire likes to try
and make me seem alhamdulillah
but um i think i think it was really
well done masha'allah i think it was
great
and as tedious as it might seem to some
people um
i think if they make it to the end uh
tying it all together a hundred percent
worth it one hundred percent worthless
all right and and i just hope that more
people kind of
just take the time out just to try to
square the circle and
and they'll find that the divine hand in
charlotte will assist them in chinatown
yeah yeah in charlotte people like
yourselves you know
i bless you all um three muslim podcasts
uh why uh why did you i mean obviously i
know you're three muslims
is there a for reason behind three
muslim vodka
you just said it yourself that's that's
literally it that's it i i think it's
brilliant
it's very it's very catchy and it's very
you know all right
yeah i came up with it and the three
characters so the link you sent me
the the first thing i noticed is
mashallah three different characters or
what
you know i i assume like you were
college friends or university friends or
you know whatever about three different
characters
so you haven't disappointed me so i have
seen you
in this chair laid back and i thought
marshall
this guy marshall this guy's
mr like so we used to in the old days
like back in the 70s we used to have a
drink called horlicks
and it would kind of calm you down and
whatever now we just do espressos and
cappuccinos
but so when i hear you it's like yeah
horlicks
[Music]
so you haven't disappointed martial
allah may allah get us to a
a position where we're as relaxed and
laid back as i know
i mean
um one point any final questions or
um sure we can begin to wrap this up
what do you think
yeah inshallah so one thing i wanted to
ask was um
you mentioned uh the i think the basic
mechanism for for darwinism for
evolution which is darwinism which is um
uh natural selection through uh random
mutation
or by random mutation um is that
i know you gave an overview of evolution
so like i guess it's bound to be
mentioned but
would it be a good idea
to just use an even more basic
understanding of evolution which is
removing the mechanism itself for the
overview because
there are i mean you did have a portion
that you missed out on in this
particular podcast
um which is the problems with with
evolution
is that a problem with darwinism
necessarily or
just evolution as a whole i'm i'm not
aware of any school in
evolutionary biology which excludes
natural selection
and random genetic mutation from the
equation as the driving
mechanism yeah um if darwin
proposed it just from
the top of his head um no one has
improved upon it
as far as i'm aware yeah and allah knows
best
and it has the it has the problem of
these are tying kind of two nebulous
nebulous terms aren't they
natural selection that in itself is very
mystical kind of nebulously out there
yeah um
so that could that is that is obviously
a great criticism
something just out there somehow is
guiding
but then they're saying that it's not
guiding it's just random and it just
turns out like that
and then you come into like it turns out
like that finely tuned and everything
all these things
begin to gel together yeah and you kind
of
i think when you look up one aspect of
something
and you don't take a step back and see
the bigger picture
you might fail to realize the wonderment
of the astonishment of the whole thing
but if you are able to step back then as
we know
you know it is it is amazing and it's
really just
hard to believe hard to believe that
it's all chance random mutations
nebulous natural selection
you know and there you have it and
obviously the question is it goes back
to
even something more basic than that
forget about how did life on planet
earth get here
but the even the the even more basic
question is just how did life in the
universe get here
yeah how did the universe itself get is
is really the quranic starting point
even if it doesn't count it in that
language you mentioned in one of your
excuse me your earlier works that the
laws of entropy
it just completely goes against natural
selection
yeah indeed because entropy finds its
way in throughout all signs where you
you go through something
quite systemized you know a system that
is quite you know
constructed and it kind of dissipates
and it gets more
uh reckless and more undefined uh with
evolution strangely enough the very
reverse happens you come with all these
kind of
you know random chaotic earth
and over time you end up with human
beings with
intelligent creatures like monkeys and
dolphins and then human beings
so it's gone against the very
normative scientific principle that
entropy
increases meaning chaos and disorder
increases with time
okay when you come to the species of
evolution
the very opposite is happening so how do
you
how do they explain that as well
then the fossil records is you know an
issue and merely because
a a fish to a a fish to a
a reptile horse even if
we we would say that's 100 proven even
if we were to say
it doesn't mean that other things it
proves other things
likewise merely because i have like 77
or 95
uh similarity in genes between me and
the great apes or me and a chimpanzee
that doesn't mean that i am descended
from it no more than
we have 50 similarity with banana genes
apparently we have 50 similarity
same genes as a banana you know and no
one's
no one on this planet is going to say we
descended
half from bananas so again it's
it's not the science it's the inference
it's the it's the conclusions uh that
one may draw from there that may not be
right
um jurassic park is a good example you
know
so these films jurassic park um the
you know uh the way that dinosaurs
behave
and the the skin of the dinosaurs
they're not based upon science they just
hollywood does it for its purpose but
you know they're they are just
artistic assumptions
yeah but there was a t-rex kind of you
know that we have
good skeletons of t-rex fossils of t-rex
but
did they have that attitude did they
blink like that
well you know did they raw like that
were their skins smooth
no that's uh that's all speculative
so something's an evolution we might
have fossils
and homo habit is home with this but a
lot of it's filling in the gap with
this is what i think's um squares a
circle
and so those type of things aren't hard
facts they could be open to change
yeah yeah just glocker yeah
yeah real quick what are your thoughts
on uh
the laws of entropy directly being you
know
discordant with natural selection
a little absent minded there bro to be
honest
i'm just pulling your leg i'm good
you're good
now are you all in the same city no no
i'm in yeah you're going around
me and fighter actually canadian
alhamdulillah oh you're canadian yeah
yeah marshall
so so most of you than the americans
yeah
absolutely my apologies to you
i think but don't apologize you know
when i looked at rami i just thought he
looks canadian
but somewhere else there's something
about him
and i don't know if it's your hat i i i
have this image of
of a canadian muslim uh wearing
a hat like yours and i actually met a
couple of colleagues i was in canada
some years ago
um where did you come from when did i oh
sorry where
where did i come where'd you come
what was that big conference that
happens in winter
oh are you talking about um uh ris
yes that's one so i was uh like uh eight
nine ten years ago i was
invited to ris and then i out
you know like you know there's about 100
speakers at this
conference okay when there only needs to
be about five speakers
you know and we can listen to them
really nicely whatever so
um after that i wasn't really i'm not
too interested in these kind of big
events and whatever uh
something like but it was really nice to
see canada and it was snowing and the
snow was right up to here and it's like
amazing stuff and the muslims were
really nice saying marshall
[Music]
so you both are in canada and and
um the third brother is yeah i'm i'm in
florida right now
you're in florida you're soaking up the
sun
that's why you're chilled out
so how do you know each other then so
you well you just hooked up online or
you know each other from time
well i met on online i met rami in the
gym
i met or rami met on her through me
and i think i met this history
two or three years ago so have you
actually physically met each other have
you physically met no we we
me and angela physically met me and
ramen physically man but those two
haven't met
yeah soon inshallah tune in we're
thinking of going on a trip as soon as
uh
as soon as this this whole thing is done
yeah
i love lettering
[Music]
of allah and god in their hearts
the same goes for you
anything else i can do for you my
brothers um i have one
really i hope it's a quick question um
i've heard
um bruce lipton talk about um his
research and stem cells and all of that
and that uh stem cells seem to uh be
reactive based on the environment
and it's it's more of an intelligent
thing
um and i've heard things like uh steven
meyer's intel uh
uh intelligent art um what's it called
intelligent design
argument and all that what do you what's
your opinion on all that
if you have um so i don't have much to
say about
lipton because simply because i haven't
engaged any of those ideas much
uh by intelligent design um
i do think i i do think the argument
of certain
complex parts of a living
creature like the eye for example i i
i find it very difficult to understand
how
that could have just come gradually it's
either all or nothing
because if it's not all or nothing it
doesn't help your chances of survival if
you've got an eye which is
not fully formed and not functioning at
all so
if it's all on all or nothing the
gradualism
has a big hole in it and i find that
even if so many years ago decades ago
there was darwin's black box that
argued this case and it gave an example
and many years later
evolutionary biologist disproved the
claim
but that doesn't disprove the idea
that this idea of uh there must be a
creative intelligence behind some of
this design because it's just it's just
really boggles the mind that this
happened through just blind chance
this there's just there's too much
there's too much artistic and complex
work
there to you know that that's how i see
it and i think i
i think i would have seen this allah
knows even if i wasn't a muslim
just it kind of it stares you in the
face yes um i probably wouldn't i
probably wouldn't
if i wasn't the most in my program think
oh well that's just one
you know that's this part of life we
don't know but you know uh as a muslim
it makes me think
um i don't believe the current
standard theory of evolution is the
final word i think the outlines are
generally that generally there
i i'm pretty s clear that the outlines
are
quite solid but i think there is
a lot of over speculation i think
science as a whole
it began to happen in my time but it
became worse after which is
if you don't tow a type of naturalistic
atheistic view
in science sometimes you have problems
with funding
and research i have friends who have
found that to be the case in their
fields
and so i think unfortunately science as
an enterprise has been slightly
politicized
in terms of atheistic kind of you know
nudges and there is no reason why
science
uh and and naturalism needs to be the
underlying assumption
of any science it doesn't it doesn't
actually follow
one doesn't have to go like go along
with the other i have an article called
um
um science
does science point towards god or
atheism on the humble eye does science
point to all gay and i give three basic
reasons
for you know why i think it points more
to now does science
point towards theism or atheism
yeah yeah that's it and you know and as
muslims we think that actually
actually science does a good job
pointing more towards more towards
theism
than it does atheism for sure yeah yeah
subhanallah um
we we always say that um it takes more
faith to disbelieve in a creator than to
believe him
absolutely absolutely but the way that
we're now conditioned
you know it's almost coming natural
because
you know we've been so conditioned to go
against the grain now
uh but then you know that's that's
partly our failing as
you know as muslims as
as the last upholders of of tolhith of
abraham ronald isn't
uh we need to prioritize our
you know our doubt some of the intro
muslim schisms
you know they're you know every you know
everything is important but everything
but
things have priority you know we're not
losing people to
uh to the the misguidance of the
classical motorcylights all right call
them
okay even though their strain of
thinking still
influences negatively a little bit here
and there but they it doesn't
it doesn't influence muslims like
atheism
new atheism and these type of
philosophies
uh and some of these people it's not
that they don't want to be good muslims
it's just that
intellectually they they're not they
can't see any way to square the circle
and
and they're convinced that science has
done good
so we're failing them perhaps you're not
failing them but
um you know religious teachers and
uh in on the whole we might be failing
them
and that's just not fair yeah
inshallah this this podcast you know
will be the start of something
you know amazing inshallah to educate
ourselves first and foremost
truth be told i don't think you need to
start but i think you already started
ages ago because i saw some of the
people that you have on here
including little stars hamza and
whatever so mashallah uh you already
started martial
may i'll give you dolphy to continue the
journey and and
and help too we didn't we didn't have
hundred stories this year we wanted
though
oh you wanted to all right so you had
others there which i i you know i kind
of skimmed some of the titles and one of
the
podcasts and i thought this looks good
yeah we are
one of one of our first guests on
mashallah masha'allah
so yeah i i and i'm sure um hamza if
when i speak to him next um i'll i'll
just say that i
i did the three podcasts and you know
they'd love to have you on so i think if
you give him an invite
he'll accept in charlotte and if you
want to see a character
and if you want to see like kind of like
i'm kind of like
like in you know let's say i'm much much
older than
um than a star hunza so you'll see
vibrancy and dynamism otherwise i'm like
um
sorry how did you pronounce your name
brother
how did you spell it for me a-n-g-h-e-l
okay so what kind of name is that
spanish
puerto rican oh puerto rican spanish
okay
it's um it's it's romanized i think
because
how would you how would you say in
spanish
so it basically means angel
but it's written with the h
i'm not an angel brother i'll tell you
that though allah knows best
no of course you couldn't be because
we're talking about evolution and human
beings so you yeah
human being
i i kind of uh people say that i come
across
pretty relaxed but not like angel right
yeah when you see your style hamza
mashallah he's vibrant on the way he'll
he'll keep you on your toes
until the end we look forward to that
inshallah
we really look forward to having one
i'll put in a word for you in childhood
even though i don't think you need a
word for it but i'll put in a word
nonetheless
it's been a real pleasure honestly
alhamdulillah just to meet you as well
just
you know really really really nice you
know three nice people my shoulder
and thank you for the opportunity of uh
of going through this uh this evolution
stuff and
physical okay for making the time
yourself and for being here and
spreading
truth where you can
honestly pleasure is all ours may allah
um
to all those watching uh what should the
hashtag be if you made it this far into
the episode
hashtag i want to put that drink that
you said on hell
how do you feel h-o-r-l-i-c-k
yeah if you made it this far
but that's jack we made it this far into
the episode may allah bless you uh
immensely we appreciate it um if you
made it this far
may allah bless you immensely
you already know that you can bring in
money now the question is
can you bring home some paychecks and
show that to mommy and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life
for you to go to college so you can get
this degree and
make this money whereas bro i keep
preaching this
you don't need school if you don't need
school if you're not trying to be a
doctor you're not trying to be a lawyer
you're not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer
right not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you could do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in ribba in interest in student
loans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm